hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Walking Dead episode 13 video
suddenly it's all happening at once just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet I didn't do facecam just so I
could get this video out just a little
bit faster there's a new round of the
walking dead giveaway is for a $20
Amazon gift card all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so let's do top 10 WTF and
comic book Easter eggs the comic book
storylines sped this along a lot faster
than they did on the TV show but a lot
of the same types of things happen it's
all march to war the characters coming
together they come together in a
slightly different way at a slightly
different pace though so number 10 Carol
finally comes to Morgan asking what
Daryl hid from her Morgan pushes it off
onto Daryl he should be the one to help
you so Carol's like sitting there in
tears like just trying to figure out
what's going on what there wasn't
telling her she has this sixth sense but
it's not until Morgan won't tell her
again like that moment where he's like
you know he should he should really be
the one to tell you that she really
senses something's up she gets that look
on her face like oh no no no that's not
good but I loved the intro with her as
she's entering like there's that montage
of her killing the walkers and in
Benjamin's like holy crap we we were
going to help you out but you're a total
badass you do not need our help at all
so number nine
Carolyn Benjamin sort of setting off the
someone else will come a long story line
someone else will come along and train
you get out of here kid oh no I can
totally skip the drop so now doesn't
Carol just feel so much more guilty if
she had agreed to let him come along he
might still be alive so each of the
characters had a moment like this that
they regret they caused their actions in
this episode or caused them to change
their behavior in this episode richard
talks about how he thought that someone
else would come along it led to the
death of his daughter katie morgan
regrets Dwayne's death his son I'll talk
about that later on my list because
there's a whole bunch of Morgan way at
the top of my list here and then later
when Carol regrets not helping Benjamin
out in this moment here she's really
also regretting all of her friends back
in Alexandria because she didn't help
out sooner so sort of the whole message
of the episode is that someone else will
not come along take action today because
tomorrow will be too late but they were
really laying it on thick with
giman character this week they want you
to feel like he's this puppy dog who's
super eager he's happy ready to learn he
has this great relationship with his
little brother who he's kind of like a
father to now so if you didn't think
that they were going to kill him before
this episode you definitely start to get
worried about him just because there are
so many extra scenes with his character
but number 8 richard slowly loses his
mind as he's digging the grave for
himself and for his daughter so it's the
big hat tip as Carol's walking by going
like somebody else's around here who
killed this Walker what's going on here
and it just everything feels really
uneasy so I love the way they built
tension in this episode when you see the
shopping carts in the background here so
number seven Richard tries to make peace
with Morgan like don't feel bad when
things go sideways because you're going
to have to kill somebody I totally
understand what you're doing here but
you're definitely going to have to kill
somebody soon so he wasn't wrong but
Morgan is probably going to ignore his
advice and still be really hard on
himself like whatever this person that
Morgan is turning into he is definitely
going to beat the crap out of himself
because like there's the painting that
Benjamin brings Morgan and he recites
that line to him when you hurt someone
else you hurt yourself
so Morgan definitely hurt himself and
I'd say that he has that giant painting
to look at for the rest of the season to
remind him of that but it seems like
Carol sort of gave him the shack on the
edge of town so that he could get away
without actually getting away but you
get the backstory about Richards
children is Richard sitting there
talking to Morgan I think it's the first
time Morgan openly acknowledges his son
in a long time every once in a while
he's mentioned him in a roundabout way
but he definitely acknowledges that
something really bad happened to Duane
if you don't remember how Dwayne died
what happened is as he was searching a
basement he left Duane with a gun with
their walker white in Duane you know
being the little kid wasn't able to
shoot his mother and kill her before she
was able to bite him Morgan was able to
kill his wife but not before it was too
late to save his son so his inaction
pushing off something he should have
done killing his wife led to the death
of his son I should have taken action
sooner so
4/6 Richards plan comes into motion and
it seems really weird like you pull up
there's the shopping cart barrier you
get really uneasy and then you sort of
remember oh wait a minute wasn't he just
digging that grave with all the shopping
carts next to him and you wonder what
he's planning but it turns out to just
be a really big stall for time they had
that moment where Ezekiel's like it's a
wonder that we're all not mad they
totally think that it was just some
random person that went completely crazy
but it's all a stall for time
so that Richard can hide that piece of
fruit so that things will just barrel
out of control when they meet with the
Savior's so number by predictably the
[ __ ] hits the fan Gavin in the Savior's
exact a price when it seems like Ezekiel
has kept the terms of their bargain so
it's not just as they forgot a piece of
fruit is the latest in a series of
setbacks in that arrangement so he lets
the buttmunch exact the price and
instead of Richard getting killed it
winds up being Benjamin and they did
this weird thing where they cut away in
they scream it was kind of a different
term for them normally I think they
would just show him being shot on
television but maybe they're responding
to people thinking that it's too violent
so the moment still worked for me your
brain sort of fills in the missing gap
like oh my god
he shot Benjamin but this might just be
a network thing you guys can let me know
do you think it was weird the way they
did this instead of him just outright
getting shot maybe they wanted to make
it even worse because your mind comes up
with something that's so much more
terrible than what they could do on
television but they hold him to Carol's
he dies on the table in it's kind of a
sad moment the Benjamin character was
always sort of superfluous like you
always sensed that something was off
about him like I can't remember if it
was in the second or the third episode
it might have been by like the fourth
episode at least that I was like they're
definitely going to kill this guy this
season he's way too innocent
he's like the Bambi of the group he's
way too eager he's not a good fighter
and he is so ready to rush into a fight
that he's definitely not going to win
and then on top of that they gave him
all these extra scenes in this episode
just so that you would feel the weight
of this moment so the moment landed for
me but it's not like watching one of the
survivors that you spent the last seven
seasons with dying but the whole thing
here is that this is sort of like the
last domino that pushes Ezekiel Carroll
in Morgan over the edge although
a lot more clear for Morgan and Carol
because they had a much stronger arc in
the episode but even though Morgan and
Richards plan continues to be a big
thing in the episode this was also sort
of the tipping point for Ezekiel where
he's like okay that's it we're going to
join the Alliance even though he doesn't
outright say that till much much later
number four Morgan finds the fruit goes
crazy almost tries to kill himself then
confronts Richard like he's ready to
kill him Richard explains the plan this
is how we do it it was supposed to be me
we have to make them believe that we
understand so Morgan seems like he's on
board but he just has murder on his face
like you don't know what he's going to
do he has that crazy nervous tic and
it's almost like you're back to season 3
Morgan where Rick finds him and he has
totally lost his mind so this is where
it starts to get really exciting number
three
jumping forward because all the really
good stuff is way higher on my list
Morgan finally comes to Carroll and just
fed up with everything
flatout tells her what happened how
negan killed Glen Abraham Spencer Olivia
how everyone was forced to work for the
Savior's and that's the final thing that
breaks her causes her to go back I
should have helped out sooner they might
still be alive
I thought that someone else would come
along the thing that Richard said
earlier because they did a great job of
weaving that theme into the entire
episode but number two Carol comes back
to Ezekiel ready to fight and he's like
well you know not today they start
planting things it was a nice callback
to Carol planting seeds in her front
yard you can burn things down but
they'll grow back that was actually one
of the best lines in the episode from
that woman that comes to talk to Ezekiel
but she's afraid of she but like I'm
just going to stay right here I'll be
fine
probably one of the best non-action
lines in the episode although the best
moment of the episode went to Morgan so
number one Morgan kills Richard huge WTF
is this big turn for his character ever
since season six we got the flashback
he's been this way so you have to
imagine that the first time that we saw
him again after that huge absence at the
beginning of season 5 that he's been
this pacifist self
it's like he's giving up his faith and
adopting his old stabby ways as he's
like whittling down his staff at the end
of the episode I love the way that they
don't show you that either you just hear
sound of him whittling a point into the
end of his death so that he'll be able
to kill people with it faster the object
of his pacifism is now the object of his
revenge but the big comic book changed
as they made in this episode I really
this part of the season is mostly with
the Ezekiel character now I mean
obviously like the Carol character is
very different in the comics she killed
herself way long time ago so they've
already changed her a bunch but comic
book Ezekiel is much more ready to fight
before he meets Rick Grimes so when you
meet Ezekiel at the beginning of this
season he's like you know we're happy
with our arrangement with the Savior's
we're not looking to start anything I'm
trying to protect these people
but comic book Ezekiel is a lot more
like Richard in that he knows that they
need to fight negan but he's waiting for
other people to come along so eventually
he meets Rick and the survivors and he's
like great I got the people I need let's
form an alliance let's fight the
Savior's the big question now is who is
going to kill negan first Carol or
Morgan because it looks like they are
both out for blood Ezekiel wants to kill
them too so now it's like who's going to
get too immersed is it going to be Rick
is it going to be Carol is it going to
be Morgan so now things are really
starting to get exciting so behind the
scenes it seems like what they're trying
to do with these last few episodes is be
kind of hopeful about it and this is all
march to war so I'm guessing that
all-out war will be like the first
couple episodes of season 8 just based
on the pace that they're going but let
me know in the comments when do you
think they will actually begin making
war against negan and the Savior's do
you think that will fall in the very
last episode or do you think we'll get
like a teaser for that at the end of
episode 15 but what's going to happen
next is is I have some new flash to post
there's some big iron fist drama the
series is dropping this week I'll try to
post that Tuesday morning you guys want
a Legion video I meant to do that before
but so much stuff happened so I'll try
to get that video Wednesday and I'll
update the video schedule in the top
comment so be sure to just check the top
comments out but congratulations to the
latest walking dead giveaway winner
logia gamer
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round of
this video on outs the winner when I
post my next Walking Dead video while
you wait for that to post there was a
whole bunch of new Game of Thrones that
dropped this weekend you can click here
for all the teasers that they drop for
the next coming season and you
click here for that trailer again thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys in the next videos tonight
everybody looks at five